-You guys, we have got
a great show tonight,
one you definitely
would want to miss --
I mean wouldn't want to miss.
Would --
Sorry, would -- You would --
[ Laughter ]
You wouldn't want it --
You would -- I meant to say --
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
You guys hear about this?
-Ugh.
-After all the backlash
to his press conference
with Vladimir Putin,
President Trump said that
the whole thing
was a big misunderstanding
because he said the word "would"
when he meant to say "wouldn't."
[ Laughter ]
The saddest part
of that explanation is that
it took him 24 hours
to come up with it.
It's like, "That's the --
That's what happened?"
"Oh, yeah, definitely."
[ Cheers and applause ]
But Trump says
he now accepts U.S. intelligence
that Russia interfered
with our election.
Trump was like,
"After 18 months as president,
I've decided
to try something totally new --
intelligence."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I'm gonna try it. I'm gonna
try some intelligence."
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right, Trump's really
in damage-control mode,
and the best excuse
he came up with
was he said "would"
instead of "wouldn't."
The whole thing
sounded kind of crazy.
But maybe that's just because
Trump's the one who said it I --
[ Light laughter ]
I wonder if it
would sound less crazy
coming out of
someone else's mouth?
Does anybody here
want to give it a shot?
Does anyone want to read
what the President said,
word for word,
see if it makes any more sense?
♪♪
Who's over here?
Yeah.
Come on.
Who wants to do it?
No one's raising their hand?
Oh, hey, yeah, yeah.
Go try, yeah, try.
We'll see, we'll see.
Yeah, try it.
Come on.
-Follow you?
-Yeah, yeah, follow me.
Yeah, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
There you go, take that.
Yeah, yeah, it's fantastic.
It's very easy.
Yeah, come here, yeah.
-Okay.
-Here you go.
Take that microphone there.
You just hit
the monologue mark here.
-I'm terrible
at public speaking.
-What is your name?
-I'm Bridget.
-Bridget?
Okay, good.
And you're terrible at pub--
perfect.
-I'm terrible.
-Perfect.
Okay, this will go great.
All right.
These are the exact words of the
President of the United States.
Let's see if they sound any
less crazy when you say them.
Take it away, Bridget.
-It should've been obvious.
I thought it would be obvious.
But, I would like to clarify,
just in case it wasn't.
In a key sentence in my remarks,
I said the word "would"
instead of "wouldn't."
The sentence should've been,
"I don't see any reason why
I wouldn't,
or why it wouldn't be Russia."
So, just to repeat,
I said the word "would"
instead of "wouldn't."
-Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There's more?
This side?
-Yeah.
-And the sentence
should have been --
And I thought it would be
maybe a little bit unclear,
on the transcript,
or unclear on the actual video.
The sentence should have been
"I don't see any reason
why it wouldn't be Russia."
Sort of a double-negative.
So can you put that in?
And I think
that probably clarifies things
pretty good by itself.
-That's -- hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Nailed it!
Actually, much better!
You can take that with you.
Thank you, Bridget, yeah.
Hey, not bad.
That's fantastic.
Bridget, thank you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Actually -- Actually,
it does make more sense.
-Oh, now I get it!
Yeah.
-Yeah, now it makes more sense
that Bridget says it.
Yeah, sure.
[ Laughter ]
Good job, pal.
You guys see this?
While he spoke to reporters,
people could see
the handwritten notes
that he was reading,
and on his sheet, he spelled
"collusion" with one L.
This is real.
Take a look.
This is a real photo.
Look at that.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
When his staff told him
that collusion has two L's,
he was like, "Got it --
two L's, just like 'Donalld.'"
[ Laughter ]
"Two L's."
D-D-D-D-O...
At his Cabinet meeting today,
Trump pushed back
against everyone who thinks that
he's too close to Russia.
Check out what he said.
-We're doing very well.
Probably as well as anybody
has ever done with Russia.
And there's been no President
ever as tough
as I have been on Russia.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
He's like, "I've been tougher
than all the presidents.
Harrison Ford, Martin Sheen,
Alec Baldwin."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"That guy
from the Allstate commercials."
Get this -- it just came out
that Trump spends more money
on Facebook ads
than any other politician.
When he heard about it,
Putin was like,
"Hey, Donald can spend allowance
however he wants."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"He can do
whatever he wants with it."
Some more political news --
I read that Starbucks founder
Howard Schultz might run
for President in 2020.
[ Cheers ]
Yeah.
He seems pretty serious
about it, too.
In fact, he's already got some
campaign slogans picked out.
For instance, there's,
"Howard Schultz --
Cooler than the center of
a Starbucks breakfast sandwich."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Mm.
Can you put this back in
for 20 seconds?"
[ Laughter ]
Next up, there's,
"Howard Schultz --
One nation, understaffed
during peak hours."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
And finally, there's,
"Howard Schultz --
Make Americano great again."
[ Cheers and applause ]
A venti Americano.
Listen to this, you guys --
the World Airlines Awards
was just announced,
and Delta was named
the top U.S. airline.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They would have
accepted the award,
but their flight to the ceremony
was delayed six hours
and then canceled.
[ Laughter ]
Eh, you get them next year.
This is very interesting.
Did you see this?
The FDA might start
to limit which drinks
can call themselves milk.
Which means that
all the companies
that make milk alternatives,
like soy milk, almond milk,
stuff like that,
they're all scrambling
to come up with new names.
-Wow.
-I don't know
if they're good or not,
but let's just check out what
some of them are considering.
For instance, almond milk
will now be called Nut Juice.
-Really?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Really?
That doesn't seem like
a good idea at all.
-I think it's good.
-That seems awful.
-I think
it clarifies everything.
Next up, peanut milk
will be called Liquid Pea.
-Okay.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Lastly, hemp milk
will now be called Bong Water.
So if you just --
Just so you know that.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
And finally,
here's a local story.
A man in New York City just set
a Guinness World Record,
and the local news
was there to cover it.
Check out what he did.
-Ashrita Furman set a new record
for slicing the most watermelon
in half on his own stomach
in one minute.
It's a very specific --
-Oh, my.
-Yeah, thing that he did.
He says he's relieved
he did not kill himself.
[ Laughter ]
-He beat the previous record,
which was zero.
No one wants to do that.
We have a great show tonight!
Give it up for The Roots!